hi all
i've been informed by many sources and
also observed online
not least because of my discussions with
a variety of muslim thinkers supporters
and critics
that i have developed an audience in the
muslim world
i would first like to say that i could
not be more pleased or honored that such
is the case
it has been so heartening to see that my
biblical lectures for example attracted
a large muslim audience
and that the comments from the muslim
watchers and listeners to my youtube
channel and podcast
have been so extraordinarily positive
and all this is lovely to see
in the aftermath of the extraordinary
abraham accords
which have laid out the possibility for
peace between all the people of the book
in an unprecedented manner
and i have something to say as an
extension of all of this
please forgive my presumption if you
would
it is time for those of you
in the muslim world
to stop fighting among yourselves you
shiites and sunnis
and also time to stop regarding the
christians and even more specifically
the jews
as your enemies
why
not least because you have the enemy
located in the wrong place
first
the best place to find satan let's say
is within
if you think the true enemy is in
someone else's heart
then you haven't thought nearly long
enough
about the darkness within
and you have therefore fallen prey to
the most subtle temptation of the
ancient
demonic spirit
so your best bet on the spiritual
warfare front is to make of yourself and
your muslim practice something so
admirable
that the light shining from your
well-constituted psyches and productive
generous and wise actions is so intense
that people convert to your faith from
sheer admiration
there's a goal
second far more unites you with the
other people of the book
as your own prophet himself peace be
unto him forthrightly said
than what divides you
you all believe for example
in a book
you all believe for example in god
and believe that you have an ultimate
duty to that god
you are all followers of a prophetic
tradition
and that is a tradition that unites the
wisdom of the past with the vision and
voice of those willing to see and speak
truly and lovingly
in the present
and you are all threatened
in a very real sense
by the system of vengeful luciferian
ideas
that currently confronts all that is
transcendent traditional and valuable
on the sexual front on the familial
front
on the conceptual front on the
psychological and sociological front
and
in the final analysis
on the theological front
so how about we all quit squabbling over
trinkets and details
and face the real problem
and i should also point out
that it is not the individual carriers
of the woke politically correct
degenerate neo-marxist ideas
that should be regarded as the enemy
either
first we must take the idea that the
satanic impulse within
is the prime enemy
with all due seriousness
second
we must understand that even those quite
possessed by the spirit of cain that
attracts and drives confused and lost
people to the luciferian ideologies of
the materialist utopians are in the
ideal
fully redeemable and only
partially consumed
even the committed student ideologues
who have for example attacked me and
others like me rather viciously are
generally say 90 percent or perhaps 80
reasonable and potentially civilized
people
who could still see the light
muslims reach across the sectarian
divide
shiites
find a sunni pen pal
communicate with someone on the other
side sunnis do the same
and then maybe reach out tentatively
to a christian or even heaven forbid
a jew
because perhaps it is time
for those who purport to be followers of
god
to act like it
and to be convincing in those actions
even to those whose premature cynicism
and skepticism
have driven them into the towers of
babel
constructed by the avatars of the
resentful intellect
is there someone in the muslim world
willing to build an electronic system to
bring people from the sunni and shiite
community together
a place where people of goodwill could
reach electronically across the divide
person to person
and to formulate the kinds of personal
trusting friendships upon which a
lasting peace truly might be founded
a place where jews and christians
willing and eager to open communication
with their muslim brothers
might do
just that
there's a task for someone looking for a
purpose and it's an open invitation to
do just that if you build it
they will come
if you build it
get in touch with me
you'll figure out how to do it
and i'll publicize it
thank you all my muslim listeners
watchers and readers
for your kind attention
and patience
i wish you well
as you strive to become the light in the
world that your faith truly demands
let's see if we can unite as people of
the book and negotiate our way
toward the paradise that we might truly
and jointly
attain